don't be fooled by this question  everyone misses Asha bought a computer  that was discounted 25 off its original  price Asha paid a total of P dollars an  amount inclusive of a 10 sales tax on  the discounted price which of the  choices represents the original price of  the computer in terms of P  let's solve this step by step let X be  the original price of the computer the  original price was discounted by 25 so  we subtract 0.25 x to get the discounted  price of 0.75 X then we need to add a  sales tax of 10 percent so we multiply  this by 1.1 to get P which is the amount  Asha paid but we want to solve for the  original price so we divide both sides  of this equation by 0.75 and 1.1 to  solve for x x is equal to P divided by  the quantity 0.75 multiplied by 1.1 and  that's answer Choice d